.
I SEE THAT OUR CHANGE OF
LOCATION DIDN'T.
CONFUSE OR DISCOURAGE ANYONE
FROM ATTENDING TODAY.
SO THAT STRATEGY COMPLETELY
FAILED.
I'M IT IS GOOD CO ALL HERE THIS
MORNING GUY AS WE BEGIN TO CLOSE
OUT THE.
BUDGET IN.
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE.
SINCE WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET WE ARE GOING TO PASS OVER
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
WHICH IS A CONSIDERABLE PART OF
OUR AGENDA TODAY.
AND WE WILL TAKE OUR ONE ITEM
TO BE HEARD THE COLOR CAL EPA'S
SACRAMENTO HEADQUARTERS ISSUE.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. SO.
YOU'D LIKE TO STEP FORWARD ON
THAT.
LET ME PRESENT TO. FEEL FREE TO
TAKE ALL THE TIME YOU WANT AS WE
WAIT FOR MEMBERS AND THEN WHEN
YOU SEE A FULL FORM WHERE YOU
CAN JUST.
HI HI.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ERIC JARVIS WITHOUT COUNTY PA.
THINK WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU THIS MORNING. AYE
THE AGENDA DESCRIBES OUR
PROPOSAL ACCURATELY AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
FOR PROOF IS BUDGETED.
SO IN ADVANCE I I WILL BE BRIEF
WITH MY COMMENTS OTHER THAN TO
EMPHASIZE A CUE FEW KEY POINTS.
THAT UNDERSCORE THE MERITS OF
THE PROPOSAL.
OUR IF IT'S NO SECRET OVER THE
YEARS CAL EPA HAS GROWN RATHER
SIGNIFICANTLY AND WE DON'T SEE
THAT TREND CHANGING. IN THE NEAR
FUTURE
SO.
WE HAVE IN OUR PROPOSAL. WE
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE AND AND
LONG STANDING.
BUSINESS NEEDS OFFICE SPACE
BUSINESS HE'S FOR ALL THE BOARDS
DEPARTMENTS DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES EXCUSE ME AND AND CAL
EPA.
AND AS WE SEE IT WE REALLY ONLY
HAVE TWO OPTIONS MAXIMIZE OUR
SPACE IN OUR CURRENT
HEADQUARTERS BUILDING. OR SEEK
OUT SPACE IN THE IN THE OPEN
MARKET IN THE GREATER DOWNTOWN
AREA.
UNFORTUNATE OUR RESEARCHERS
SHOWN THAT THAT LAST OPTION IS
QUITE COSTLY.
IN FACT WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE
OPERATIONAL COST OF OUR
HEADQUARTERS BUILDING IT IT
AVERAGES OUT TO A LITTLE OVER
TWO DOLLARS A SQUARE FOOT. ONE
FORTUNATELY IN THE OPEN MARKET
OUR RESEARCH IS SHOWING ITS
UPWARDS OF THREE TO SOMETIMES
DOING A HALF DOLLARS A SQUARE
FOOT. SO THAT OUR PROPOSAL YOU
YOU MIGHT HAVE RECOGNIZED A
CHART THAT CHART TRIES TO SHOWS
THAT SHOW THAT DISTINCTION OF
HOW MUCH MONEY WE WE WOULD BE
SPENT ON THE OPEN MARKET. AND
THROUGH OUR PROPOSAL IF YOU WERE
TO ADOPT THAT TODAY WE STAND TO
SAVE THE STATE UPWARDS OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE
OF TEN YEARS. AND AND THEN OF
COURSE AS AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
COUNTY PA WILL ENDORSE WE
SUSPECT EVEN LONGER TERM SAVINGS
ACTING OUT YEARS.
SO FROM FROM OUR STANDPOINT THIS
JUST MAKES GOOD BUSINESS
SAMSON AND ESPECIALLY FROM A
FISCAL STANDPOINT AND I'LL LEAVE
YOU A THREE THREE KEY POINTS.
AS YOU KNOW WE THE STATE WILL ON
THIS BUILDING AT THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
AND SO.
WERE CASHING IN ON THE STATE'S
TWENTY FIVE YOUR INVESTMENT OF
PURCHASING THIS BUILDING AT THE
LOW COST OF ONE DOLLAR SO IT
BECOMES A NICE STATE AS.
WERE ALSO MAXIMIZING HONO
CURRENT FOOTPRINT IN
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST EVER LEAD
PLATINUM BUILDING.
AS YOU MIGHT KNOW KELLY PA'S
ARE.
PRETTY WELL KNOWN BUILDINGS VERY
PRESTIGIOUS AND WHAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT.
WITH KEEPING OUR FOLKS IN HOME.
AND THEN FINALLY.
BY ADOPTING THIS PROPOSAL RIGHT
HERE IN TO THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM A FEW YEARS
AGO THAT REQUIRES ALL STATE
AGENCIES TO MAXIMIZE THEIR CO
FOR. KURT CURRENT FOOTPRINT SEES
ME AND SHY AWAY FROM.
LEASE SPACE OUTSIDE OF STATE
COFFERS.
SO WHEN YOU CONSIDER ALL THAT IF
IT JUST MAKES GOOD BUSINESS
SENSE TO TO ADOPT OUR PROPOSAL.
AND I NOTICED IN THE STAFF
AGENDA THERE WAS A QUESTION
ABOUT.
.
HOW WE ARRIVED AT THESE COSTS
AND IF YOU PLEASE THE CHAIR I'M
HAPPY TO GO OVER THAT?
THEY'RE NOT THAT DON'T CONCLUDE
YOU COULD GIVE US.
KIND OF AND.
AN OUTLINE OF.
HOW YOU ARRIVED AT THAT WOULD
BE SURE?
AND AS YOU KNOW THIS IS PHASE
ONE OF THE TWO PHASE PROJECT
PHASE ONE. IS ONLY INVOLVING THE
AIRPORT THE WATER BOARD CAO
RECYCLE AND AND WE HIGH SO
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE THE ONLY THE
ONES BEARING THE COST BECAUSE OF
TODAY.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IN THE WAY WE
COST ALLOCATE ALL OF OUR
BUILDING EXPENSES WE TRY AND DO
A FAIR SHARE AN EQUITABLE SHARE
BASED ON.
AGENCY SIZE
SO FOR THE FLOORS IT WILL BE
IMPACTED AIR BE HAS THE BIGGEST
FOOTPRINT THEN THE WATERBOARDING
TERRACYCLE BEEN A WEEK. AND SO
THAT'S HOW THE COSTS WILL BOARD
TO APPROVE WARM THROUGH
APPROPRIATE. TIME PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
.
THE.
TWENTY THREE A MILLION DOLLAR
ROUGHLY.
ACOSTA IT'S A A IN THIS
PROPOSAL.
COVERS THE RETROFITTING OF
APPROXIMATELY HOW MANY OFFICES I
UNDERSTAND IT. I THINK IT IT'S
CREATING UP ABOUT A THOUSAND
NEW.
THE CUBICLES YEAH BUT IT ALSO
RETROFITS OR. RE A GREAT DOES.
A AT A NUMBER OF OTHERS YES
WITH ITS THIS IS SOMEWHAT LIKE A
LEASE RENEWAL SO WE WILL
RECONFIGURE ALL THE FLOORS WILL
DO OBVIOUSLY TO PAINT CARPET AND
THEN RECONFIGURE CUBICLES.
AND SO OFTEN IT'LL BE OVER THE
COURSE OF EIGHT YEARS TO WHERE
WE CAN WE WILL WE WILL REALIZE
ELEVEN HUNDRED AND CUBICLES AS
THAT IS THE PLAN.
YOLANDA REALIZING ADDITIONAL
ELEVEN HUNDRED OVER THE COURSE
THAT ALL OF ELEVEN HUNDRED
PONIES IS YES.
EIGHT IT'S A TOTAL LETTERS A
GRAND TOTAL.
I SEE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIDE OF.
LEO.
SHAWMUT MEANT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE TOOK A
LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL AND.
ASSUMING THAT THEY APA CONTINUES
TO GROW AND THE POSITIONS ARE
FILLED WITH THINK YOU REALIZE
POTENTIALLY SOME MODEST SAVINGS
IN THE FIRST FOUR YEARS AND THEN
BEGINNING IN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN. SAVINGS
ON THE ORDER OF MAGNITUDE OF
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
THAT WOULD BE ONGOING.
GREAT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NOTHING GREAT.
.
THEN.
LET'S SAY A.
CALL ROLE AND TO SEE IF WE CAN.
BUT ON THIS ITEM
BLOOM.
HERE FONG HERE KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
IS THERE A A MOTION TO.
PROVE THE ISSUE ONE UNDER CAL
EPA.
I'LL SECOND THAT.
BLOOM.
HI FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RUN THE ITEM TO BE HEARD ISSUE
ONE HOME.
ALRIGHT WE'LL HOLD THAT ITEM
OPENED.
AND NOW WE WILL GO BACK TO THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE VOTE ONLY COUNTER
HAVE SOME.
CLARIFICATIONS OR CORRECTIONS
TO WHAT TELL YOU SEE ON THE UP.
AGENDA FOR.
THE FOLLOWING ISSUES IN THAT
SO THAT.
THE AT THE AGENDA THE PRINTED
AGENDA HOUSE.
.
DIFFERENT STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
BUT WHAT WE WILL BE VOTING ON ON
FOOD ONLY ISSUE TWENTY TWO.
WILL BE AN ACTION TO CONFORM TO
THE SENATE. YOU MIGHT WANNA MAKE
NOTES IN YOUR PRINTED AGENDA IS
IF YOU IF YOU HAVE THEM. AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE THIS AGAIN.
BEFORE WE BEGIN VOTING.
SO ON ISSUE TWENTY TWO.
THE ACTION WILL BE TO CONFORM TO
THE SENATE.
ONE VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTY TO
THE ACTION WILL BE TO APPROVE IS
BUDGETED. ALONG WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
TO REQUIRE D. W. ARE TO REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. ON
INFORMATION ON THE POSITIONS
FILLED.
ON VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTY FOR
THE ACTION WILL BE TO APPROVE
THE BCP. ON A THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS
AND ADDITIONALLY ADOPT
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE.
SFB CDC TO REPORT ON SPECIFIED
INFORMATION.
AND FINALLY ON VOTE ONLY ISSUE
THIRTY NINE THE ACTION WILL BE
TO APPROVE AS BUDGET THAT.
SO WITH THAT IS THERE A MOTION
TO APPROVE ITEMS.
ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT NINE.
ELEVEN THROUGH SIXTEEN.
EIGHTEEN THROUGH THIRTY TWO.
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN AND
THIRTY NINE THROUGH FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU.
THAT FLOW.
I.
FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
WILLA HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
ANTON'S.
AND IS THERE A MOTION.
ON ISSUES TWO SEVEN SEVENTEEN.
AND THIRTY THREE TO THIRTY FIVE.
SECOND.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
THEIR MOTION ON ISSUE THREE.
SECOND.
BLOOM I.
FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN. PATTERSON.
TO HEAR MOTION ON ISSUE SIX.
SECOND. BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
AND EMOTIONAL ISSUE TEN PLEASE.
SECOND. BLOOM BY FALL.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
AND FINALLY I IS OUR MOTION ON
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT. VOTE
ONLY.
AND SECOND. BLOOM. AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND ADJUST TO
A TO RECAP BEGAN NOT.
THE VOTES THAT WE JUST TOOK
INCLUDE. THE FOLLOWING
CLARIFICATION THERE CHANGES IN
THE RECOMMENDATION.
THAT'S ON THE PRINTED AGENDA.
ON VOTED ONLY ISSUE TWENTY TWO
THE ACTION WILL BE TO CONFORM TO
THE SENATE. ON VOTE ONLY ISSUE
THIRTY TO THE ACTION WILL BE TO
APPROVE IS BUDGET ALONG WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
TO REQUIRE D. W. ARE TO REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. ON%
INFORMATION ON THE POSITIONS
FILLED.
ON VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTY FOUR
THE ACTION IS TO APPROVE THE BCP
ON A THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
BASIS. AND ADDITIONALLY ADOPT
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
TO REQUIRE SFB CDC TO REPORT ON
SPECIFIED INFORMATION. AND ON
VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTY NINE THE
ACTION IS TO APPROVE AS BUDGET
IT.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THE
AGENDA OPEN. AND DATA.
THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING THIS.
ABBREVIATED MEETING. BUTTA WILL
ADJOURN AFTER WE GET TO A.
OF THE ADD ONS.
TO ADD ON
.
PART WILL ITTAKE MR PATTERSON
SAT ON VOTES NOW.
I AND VOTE ONLY ISSUES ONE FOUR
FIVE EIGHT NINE ELEVEN THROUGH
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN THREE THIRTY TO
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY
NINE OR FORTY FOUR.
I
PATTERSON.
FOLKS COULD YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
I'M VOTE ONLY ISSUES TO SEVEN
SEVENTEEN THIRTY THREE THREE
THIRTY FIVE PATTERSON NO
MISTER MULLIN HAS ARRIVED IT
WILL ADD ON.
A VOTE ONLY ISSUES ONE FOUR
FIFTY FIVE EXCUSE ME.
VOTE ONLY. ITEMS TWO ONE FOUR
FIVE EIGHT NINE ELEVEN THROUGH
SIXTEEN EIGHT THREE EIGHTEEN
THREE THIRTY TO THIRTY SIX
THIRTY SEVEN. THIRTY NINE
THROUGH FORTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE
AS FOUR ZERO.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES TO SEVEN
SEVENTEEN THIRTY THREE THROUGH
THIRTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE TO TO
CHAIR VOTING AYE MULLIN.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE THREE CURRENT
VOTE TO ONE.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. BLOOM
VOTING AYE MULLIN.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE SIX CURRENT VOTE
FOUR ZERO MULLIN.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE TEN CURRENT
VOTE.
TWO EYES TO NOT VOTING THE
CHAIRS VOTING AYE MULLIN.
ITEMS TO BE HURT ISSUE ONE
CURRENT VOTE TO ONE MR FUNG'S
NONVOTING CHAIR VOTING AYE
MULLIN.
BOOKS ARE A LITTLE MORE.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE. TO.
EYES TO NOT VOTING CHAIR VOTING
AYE MULLIN.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN. OUR
MEETING IS ADJOURNED